I don't use drugs I never really have
gotten into marijuana I have no interest
but I took psychedelics and I'm proud to
say that I wouldn't write the way I
write I wouldn't think that way I think
likewise I wouldn't have understood the
nature of cultural relativism as an
anthropologist I wouldn't treat women
the way I do our parents used to say
don't take these things you'll never
come back the same that was a whole
bloody point right and so so so I I
think that the one of the very positive
things going on today it's a very
judicious and cautious at feels cautious
revitalization of these psychedelics and
finally the recognition that these
substances can be legitimate tools for
clinical use in certain cases and for
research so so I mean I all this stuff
is is moving ahead it's just it's not
going to be smooth because the the
changes that we're endorsing are
profoundly unsettling to those not
prepared to recognize and the fact that
the genies out of the bottle ain't going
back and the tsunami of social change
and transformation and spiritual growth
and reinvention of our entire sense of
ourselves in the planet it's rolling
forward and you know get out of the way
if you're not prepared because you can
it'll drown you if you're not prepared
to float upon it yeah
[Applause]